Arthur's guarded if you don't know what
Arthur is just watch Arthur how would
you even describe our fun children's TV
but it's so good that an adult could
probably enjoy it yeah like it is
literally made for like five-year-olds
but it's written so well that like again
like as an adult you're like this is not
it's it's so weird because it kind of
hides its very adult themes in a very
like friendly for children type of way
like I think it's really I think Arthur
is one of the best shows when it comes
to subtle writing yeah where it's like
before you realize it this character has
been built up to be something that you
can kind of be like yeah I I get what
you're going through bro this is some
really good episodes yeah even when I
was like 16 yeah come back from school
if Arthur was on I'd watch Arthur oh
yeah yeah I loved Arthur speaking of
Banger openings
one of the most legendary cartoons
ingrained in my mind
etched in dude everybody thought they
were roster when they were listening to
this [ __ ] you know but uh very much a
shame that it's gone
you're a legend in our hearts it's it's
weird because I know I watched so many
episodes of Arthur I don't I don't know
if I was just too young no you do yeah
but I don't like remember much of it
it's it's it's it's only through memes
that I'm like oh yeah this kind of
happened wearing the headphones yeah
wearing the headphones on top of the
years yeah the [ __ ] Arthur fist yeah
that's Legendary Legendary now what what
about that uh what was it it was the the
meme of um what's the [ __ ] bulldog
looking guy and he's like yeah I can't
remember and he's like and he puts the
headphones in he just like starts
tripping oh yeah I love it I love that
one it's so good it's such a really good
show okay
um the final two ones are very
Australian they look they look
Australian holy [ __ ] which one do you
want to start with okay uh Russell coits
all Aussie Adventures okay so this was
um do you know the show Katherine Kim no
it's like very like one of the most
quintessential Australian sitcom shows
very very nice we're only uh important
neighbors yeah well okay so it was it
was if if neighbors is like number one
Captain kim'sly number two it's like one
of the most beloved shows um I thought
about putting that on there but this guy
uh he's uh I keep forgetting the guy's
name the actor's name but he's also a
comedian Russell no so Russell Coit is
this character oh so basically this is a
parody of like a kind of survival like
Steve Irwin's survival in Australia type
of educational show except this guy
whose real name is not Russell Queen
he's an actor he plays this character
called Russell Coit who's like the most
stereotypical like yeah I'm a you know
I'm a survival expert out Australia and
he tries to give and it's it's just the
sketch comedy show where it's Russell
Coit just trying to like kind of tell
you about like how this like this is how
you build a flyer in Australia or like
oh I just found a a red belly black
snake here's how you like get rid of it
but it always ends up in the most like
horrific ways oh that's awesome there's
this one scene where he's talking to
some indigenous Australian people
um and uh and and and he's kind of like
getting them to like you know teach them
about like how to like pick berries in
the wildlife yeah yeah learning from
them but there's this reoccurring joke
in in Russell Coit where every time
Russell Coit goes up to someone and
gives him a handshake there's this one
clip that replays every single handshake
so it's like it's just it's almost like
the stock image video of just the
close-up of the hands right hand shaking
these two white guys handshaking and it
plays every time Russell Coit goes up to
a new person and gives him a handshake
so this is one end of one episode where
he's talking to these like indigenous
Australians and he's going up to
handshake all of them every time he goes
into handshake it just cuts to two white
guys handshaking every and it's like
it's this show is like that sounds like
a meme yeah it oh it is it dude like
when people go back so like adults or
both oh yeah like it's there were some
there were some instances where like it
was very like adult oriented where like
he would actually get hurt in the show
but in like a comedic kind of way but it
was just so incredibly funny because
it's one of the most perfect examples of
just really subtle comedy in like sketch
comedy shows right I don't know how well
it is aged today uh it might be you know
because I think this is from like the
late 90s I think early 90s okay today's
falling yeah yeah so some a lot a lot of
comedies of age Paul a lot of comedies
very
and another comedy that might have aged
poorly from that time is this one uh
it's called fat Pizza
um
so this is a show
so Kevin right our boy Kevin Kevin yeah
we [ __ ] bonded over the show again
the other day when we were when we were
in Australia because this is one of
those shows where I think everyone in
our age group watched this show all
right um so basically like you guys were
talking about Peep Show being like the
peak of like British cringe comedy yeah
this is probably the Australian
equivalent to it right okay so it's this
show about uh this this guy Paulie uh
who is this like uh Italian Australian
immigrant
um and it's basically about his
character he's like a pizza delivery guy
okay and he works at this like really
[ __ ] sketch pizza shop right this
really sketch neighborhood of Australia
um and it's basically just like the
daily shenanigans that he gets up to
where he has to deal with like these
like [ __ ] horrendous like Bogan
customers and like uh because uh Paul
Paulie this actor's name I think his
actual real name is Paul as well right
um and uh all of the cast members are
like you know uh Italian immigrants in
Australia or like uh like Lebanese
immigrants in Australia and it's just
like a lot of the it's it's it's very
much revolved around like kind of the
European and Middle Eastern immigrants
who migrated to Australia so a lot of
that kind of Comedy exists but you don't
have to be part of that race to
understand that comedy because it's so
ingrained in Australian comedy
um there's a really famous actress now
in Hollywood uh Rebel Wilson I think her
name is she started off in this show wow
Rebel Wilson she's not in this picture
oh no this is right there oh okay yeah
so she she started off this was like the
show that made her famous in Australia
she played this character called Tula
who is this like [ __ ] obese-like girl
who like keeps ordering pizzas from from
this one okay yeah okay and uh and it's
just like it's it's really [ __ ]
difficult to explain but basically it's
hearing you guys talk about Peep Show is
basically the Australian equivalent of
that take a lot of cringe okay great
great I'm already interested
yeah it's incredibly cringe and it can
be incredibly offensive at times but
also really really funny yeah
um my Australian Brothers I know you get
you guys get your sarcasm your cringe
humor oh that's that's why like I would
be very interested to watch this yeah I
[ __ ] love it I feel this is the
perfect window into what Australian like
you know comedy and like Civilization is
kind of like super sexy
we live in a civilization because to be
fair I have been to some places in like
kind of outer Australia yeah where it
gives off this Vibe okay like these are
like they're exaggerations I think of
people that exist in real life yeah yeah
is is there a particular scene that uh
sticks out oh [ __ ] I don't know so like
uh like there's this one scene where
like uh Paulie gets like uh he has like
this uh friend who this Lebanese friend
uh called Habib
um and he like pisses off Habib for
doing something and then habib's just
like don't [ __ ] get in my way bro I'm
gonna call up all my cousins and then
he's just like how many cousins do you
have here and then five minutes later
there's just like over the hill there's
just these like 40 cars just full of
these Lebanese dudes that just like rock
up to the pizza shop and just start
beating the [ __ ] out of Paulie
and then and then Habib he he's like
this character he plays like this like
stereotypical like Lebanese Australian
guy so every time he takes off his shirt
it's just like completely just like full
of hair like you can't see any of his
skin at all and it just like kind of
plays into those stereotypes yeah but
not in like a way where it's like racist
if that makes sense it's just like a lot
of like just very you know
tongue-in-cheap like slapstick comedy
yeah yeah um that's very Australian all
right um and yeah that's uh my I don't
watch TV tonight how hard was it to make
this to be fair thinking about it now I
would probably replace maybe like
because I completely forgot about Top
Gear yeah yeah I'm like I mean I could
have put that down and I'm like what the
[ __ ] I watched so much [ __ ] Top Gear
so like yeah
we just try hard yeah
bottom gear but uh yeah here you go so
all right